[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE FARRAH: Well,
thank you for having us.
We're going to start
by showing a video.
We make a lot of them.
We did a big event in
California 49 earlier this year.
You might have heard
about-- unfortunately,
this was the event where Will
Ferrell got into a car accident
afterwards.
Thankfully, everyone was OK.
It's a nonpartisan campaign,
and we put together a live event
with Billy Eichner,
who came up with Glam
Up the Midterms
and Ron Burgundy.
So we can show you that, and
then we can talk about some
of the success that
we had with that event
and what we have coming up
the final six weeks, the home
stretch.
I hope voting is more
popular than this panel.
[LAUGHTER]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Your host for the
evening, Billy Eichner!
- California congressional
district 49 makes some noise!
[CHEERING]
The one, the only Ron Burgundy!
- Great to be back here.
(SINGING) Oceanside,
Oceanside, it's
right by the side of the ocean.
I recorded that song for
the chamber of commerce.
It reduced tourism by 80%.
- There's more things that
we have in common than things
that we disagree on.
- Here, here.
- Find someone in
your neighborhood
and make sure that you're taking
them to the polls on the fifth.
- There are no more excuses.
We are all going to
get out there and vote.
We're going to make sure
our friends go vote,
our families go vote.
- I voted.
- Never actually voted
in a midterm election,
and that's a huge mistake.
So this year it's
going to change.
- We're going to vote.
- We're all voting.
- And you should, too.
- I will vote, dammit!
- And we're going
to turn the midterms
into the hottest, sexiest
event of the entire year.
That's what Glam Up the
Midterms is all about.
- And that's fantastic.
- Take it for me, Ron Burgundy,
nothing is sexier than voting.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE FARRAH: So
the 2016 cycle we
had done a campaign
with Judd Apatow,
and we actually got about
a 1 and 1/2 million people
registered to vote,
mainly in California,
so we wanted to scale out into
a national campaign, which
has had its pros and cons.
But we were really
proud of the success
that we had down
in California 49.
It led to-- we've been
proud that the content
that we've made,
the whole premise
has always been to
actually get action
and to sign people up to vote.
So a few of the stats--
we had 4,000 voters sign up
for election alerts, and most
importantly, 70% of voters
under the age of 35.
We had 14 million social media
impressions, and 500 volunteer
hours to engage that many
voters, which is actually
a very high conversion rate.
You guys may not know this,
but in the 2014 cycle,
guess how many
millennials actually
showed up to the polls?
AUDIENCE: Two.
[CHUCKLING]
KATE LILLY: Two total.
MIKE FARRAH: You're even
more pessimistic than we are.
[CHUCKLING]
Add 10% to that.
It was 12% of millennials showed
up to vote in the midterms.
And you know, what
we really care about
is just the democratic process,
and getting as many people
aware, and understanding how to
vote, making it easy for them.
You know, Billy, who has an
amazing social media presence,
he tweeted out, like, seriously,
why don't people vote?
And the comments back
were just so discouraging,
in terms of just pure
apathy, laziness,
being unaware with
what's going on,
not feeling like
their vote counts.
And so we've always--
with this campaign and
others at "Funny or Die,"
we've always tried
to figure out how
to make engaging comedy
that actually gets
noticed, and breaks
through all the noise,
so that we can turn
that number around.
Because regardless of if you're
a Republican or a Democrat,
democracy only works if
people are active in it,
and actively participating.
And so we have our
leanings, but that's not
the point of the campaign.
The point is to really
engage young people
and make a difference.
And Kate, you can kind
of speak about what we're
doing the final six weeks.
KATE LILLY: Yeah, Glam
Up was started with Billy
and "Funny or Die" because we're
aware that, as an entertainment
platform, we have a
responsibility as much
as we can to use that
platform to reach people
for causes that are important
to our democracy, as Mike said.
So for Glam Up, the point
of every event and video
that we do is to leverage
views, or leverage
an exciting invite
to something cool
with Ron Burgundy
and Billy Eichner.
And instead of
purchasing a ticket,
and using that money to
fundraise or pay back
the event, "Funny or Die"
has gone out, fundraised,
put these events on.
In order to attend
one of those events,
you have to register to vote
or prove that you already
are registered to vote, and then
you are entered into the event,
and you get to go see
a cool comedy show.
So we're trying to use
that as an incentive
to say, hey, registering to
vote and showing up to the polls
is pretty easy.
You might never get to see
a show with these two people
again.
Come and do it.
It's bribery-- no, but it works.
It's really worked for us.
So what we're doing for the
remaining couple weeks--
we have a big push coming.
We have an event coming
up in Detroit, Michigan.
Detroit is an area
where they've struggled
to get people out to the polls,
specifically the youth vote.
So Billy will be having some
surprise guests with him,
performing on stage.
And that is October 7th.
And so we'll be specifically
targeting the area,
and trying to get people
to show up at the event.
That's in partnership with
the Natural Resources Defense
Council.
And then we have
three events that'll
take place in October that are
in partnership with the Human
Rights Campaign.
So let's see.
We'll be in Phoenix on the 13th
of October, Vegas on the 20th,
and Milwaukee on the 27th--
all three places, again,
being lower number
of voting districts,
specifically for the youth vote
in the midterm elections.
And then we're going
to kind of wrap it up
with a big final push
in Houston, which
is Gabby Gifford's campaign.
And we'll be putting on a
big event there as well.
So for Billy-- you know,
Billy is a working actor.
He's got a lot going on.
But he's doing this out of
the kindness of his heart
because he knows how important
it is, and carving time out
of his schedule to show up, as
well as the "Funny or Die" team
who is producing these
events, to get people out,
put on a good show, and
in the meantime have
them register to vote.
MIKE FARRAH: Yeah,
the only other thing
I would add that I think is
really cool about the campaign.
You might have
noticed we interviewed
some local activists onstage.
One thing we
definitely didn't want
do is just be a bunch of
Hollywood liberals showing up
in these different
cities and kind
of just preaching to the
choir, or just berating people
to vote.
And so it was a
really smart idea
to engage the local
community, have
a lot of local activists
onstage talking,
from their own experience
in the community,
how you can get involved.
Because then it just
feels more authentic.
Because I think there was
backlash in the 2016 cycle.
I think there was
lots of reasons.
And we don't have to
get into all of that.
But I think something
that's really
important to us is
that if we're going
to do a national
campaign, and we're
going to be speaking
to young folks,
let's not just be people
in our 30s and 40s,
talking down to them.
But let's really use smart
comedy and smart conversation
to hopefully inspire them.
Because if they're
inspired, then they
can get their friends
inspired, and it
becomes this groundswell.
Because midterms, if
you think about it,
it's terrible branding.
It sounds like a test that
you're trying to avoid.
So we try to make it
fun, and sexy, and cool,
but also really grounded
in the local environment
so that it's not
just people from LA
flying in and flying
out, but the conversation
and the work that we're doing
can then have ripple effects
throughout the community.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: Great.
Thanks.
And we will start a
discussion with you,
a little more about what
you're doing in a little bit.
I'd like to hear from Kathleen
now more about VoteRiders.
KATHLEEN UNGER:
So hi, everybody.
And thank you Nadine, and
Mike, and Kate, and all of you
who are here and interested
in the very foundation
of our country,
the right to vote.
11% of voting age Americans--
that's roughly 25 million
eligible voters--
do not have a current
government-issued photo ID.
And why is that important?
Because from a voter
ID perspective,
that's essentially
the kind of ID
that is common to all 35 states
that have these voter ID laws--
25 million.
Now, you compare that
to the margin of victory
for the year 2000 presidential
election, which was 537.
The November 2016 presidential
election was basically 77,744.
I know you all like data, so I
thought I'd be really precise.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so 25 million.
Now, on top of that,
there are many,
many, many millions
of Americans who
are so confused and
intimidated by these voter
ID laws that they
won't vote, even
though they have a valid ID.
And on top of this, you've got
a federal voter registration ID
law that applies in every state,
except for North Dakota, that
doesn't have voter registration.
Also, in some states, they have
their own voter registration ID
laws.
So there are all these IDs.
It's incredibly confusing
because these laws are really
actually very
complicated and onerous.
And it doesn't help when states
run off the range with it
as well.
For instance, right
now in Georgia
they're using a voter
registration form
that's an old voter
registration form that actually
shows that you need a photo ID
in order to register to vote.
You do not need a photo ID to
register to vote in Georgia.
You need one to vote, but
not to register to vote.
Now on top of this
confusion is the fact
that the vast majority
of people don't really
understand that voter
ID is in addition to
and different from
voter registration.
And I'll bet you that almost
everybody in this room
really doesn't understand that.
I've had all these
conversations,
and at the end of it,
people are still talking
about voter registration.
OK, so the formula
is voter registration
plus voter ID equals vote.
So VoteRiders is the practical
and effective solution.
Our mission is to ensure
that voters can actually
exercise their right to
vote because they have
an acceptable ID if it's
required in their state,
and they feel confident
that they have the right ID.
And they feel confident
if their state doesn't
have a voter ID law,
like in California
and 14 other states plus DC.
Coming back to this
confusion factor,
there are poll workers in
every state who are confused.
They're not well-trained.
The voting process
itself is confusing.
But again, all over
California, there
are poll workers who are asking
people for their voter ID,
and there is absolutely none
required in this state when
you go to vote.
So what do we do?
We identify, we inform, and
we assist voters all the way
through the process of
getting their voter ID.
We'll cover the cost of
the underlying documents.
We cover the cost and handle
the arranging of transportation
for people who need it in
order to get to the government
ID issuing offices.
And while we work with hundreds
of organizations all over,
we focus especially
on states that
have highly competitive
House, Senate,
and gubernatorial races, because
those are really where there's
a higher voter interests.
Where there's higher
voter interest,
these people want
to vote, we want
to make sure you're
going to be able to vote.
And we've contributed decisively
in an increase in voters,
especially including last
year in Virginia and Alabama.
So here we are in California.
There's no state voter ID law.
Why do we care?
Well, if there's an issue
that you care about,
it really does matter that
the people who agree with you
can vote, regardless
of where they live.
And who are these people
who are having problems?
Who's impacted by
these voter ID laws?
They're primarily those who
do not have a current driver's
license in their state.
They are older adults who are
no longer driving, if they ever
did.
They have mobility problems.
They are young adults, exactly
whom we've been talking about.
They're going to school
in another state.
They're riding bicycles.
They're taking public
transportation.
They're using ride
hailing car services.
And they're people
with disabilities.
One in five Americans
has a disability.
Obviously a lot of these
people are not driving.
They are voters of color.
And across the board, they
are voters with low income,
who cannot afford to take
the time off from work,
who cannot afford what can be
really a relatively expensive
cost of getting the underlying
documents that you need
in order to get
the free voter ID.
And then they're women.
Because a number of states
require an exact match
between the name on your
ID and the name of which
are registered to vote.
So I just want to
highlight three programs
that we're very excited about.
The first is we've created
these wallet-size voter ID
information cards
for all 50 states,
in English and in Spanish.
They show the highlights
of what's required.
And they are uniquely valuable,
because they are precisely
accurate.
So this is very
helpful because it lets
people know what they need.
And they put it in their wallet,
and it gives them confidence.
They go into the polling
place, and now they're
dealing with a
misinformed poll worker.
They take it out, it
gives them something
to hold onto literally.
So these are great.
And there is an
impact on turnout.
November 2016, in
Houston, Harris County,
our partner Mi
Familia Vota Texas
distributed our cards while
they canvassed in six majority
Latino precincts.
After the election,
the Harris County clerk
reported that turnout
countywide had decreased 1%,
but for those six precincts, it
had increased cumulatively 92%,
almost 9% per precinct.
This really can
make a difference.
So that's one.
We're thrilled about this,
and we're distributing them
by the millions, far and wide.
And they're freely downloadable.
Secondly, we are partnering
with organizations
that engage in canvassing,
and phone banking, and text
banking, and tabling.
And what they're
doing is they're
inserting into their script
a voter ID question which
we always want to be, do you
have a current driver's license
in whatever this state is?
Because people understand
what a driver's license is.
They may not know
if it's current,
but they understand
what that is.
Frankly, any other question,
you're going to come across
people who don't--
it's not that clear.
So they insert that
question, and then
anybody who responds
with anything
other than a resounding
yes, the voter file
comes to us at
VoteRiders, and we then
follow up to assist
them to make sure
that they have the
ID that they need,
that they've got their
questions answered,
that they are fully prepared,
fully confident voters.
Lastly, along with our
partner, Democracy Labs,
we have developed a
bilingual VoteRiders chatbot
for devices that use Google
Dialogflow and Google Cloud
and there are current versions
in SMS, Facebook, and Alexa.
And we will be expanding into
Android phones, and Google
Home, and WhatsApp, and
interactive voice response.
So anyway, I look forward to
your ideas and your questions.
Thank you.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So much interesting information.
I think we'll start
with Mike and Kate.
Can you talk to us about
comedy and politics,
and how they
intersect, and what do
you think is the added value
that comedy adds to politics?
MIKE FARRAH:
Traditionally, comedy
is when you speak to power.
It's a voice that
speaks to power.
And I think with the advent of
shows like "The Daily Show,"
and how the internet
and social media
has been able to inform
young folks in ways
that the news never
really got to--
I grew up watching, like,
Peter Jennings on the news.
And now the news, in that form,
is obviously really a dying
conversation.
It's a very old demographic.
And I think comedy has done a
very good job both informing
folks and entertaining them.
And we've tried to
do it in our own way,
with "Between Two Ferns"
and Zach Galifianakis.
We did a very effective
episode with President Obama
around the Affordable
Care Act a few years ago.
And that was just
really tremendous.
That led to a 40%
increase in young people
signing up for the
Affordable Care Act.
Our point of view
was this was already
a law that had been passed.
And so we were fortunate to
have a very young audience.
And we had a show that
really connected with people.
And to the President and
the White House's credit,
we didn't make it a commercial
for the Affordable Care Act.
Really, we don't start talking
about that until about maybe
2/3 of the way into the video.
And so it's always been
a very effective tool
if you do it in the right way.
If you in the wrong way, it
can come off really lame--
KATE LILLY: And preachy.
MIKE FARAH: --or preachy.
And so I think actually, if
you guys want to stick around
at the end, we're going to
show a video that we launched
that Kate produced
that stars Billy
Eichner and a few
other famous friends
at the end of the panel.
And that's something we
just released yesterday,
and it's already just
about at 1 million views.
And so you'll see,
hopefully, hopefully, you'll
think it's funny.
And hopefully, we
just think it's
the way that we've always
found traction communicating
with our audience.
It's so important to have
credibility and currency
with young people.
Like we were talking
about earlier,
if things feel inauthentic or
forced, it's a major turnoff.
And because comedy, so
effectively-- good comedy--
can speak to power in ways that
make complicated things more
accessible, that's
what we lean into.
KATE LILLY: But just to add--
I want to emphasize the
point that when we make--
because my role at "Funny or
Die," outside of producing
"Glam Up the Midterms" has
been running a digital team
for the last few years.
And actually, my first day, my
first month was October 2016.
So we weren't sure
what was going
to hit us in November of
2016, and as you can imagine,
that was a journey
to figure it out
with the team along the way.
But I think it's
really important
that the writing and the talent
and the message of the video
is not something that exists
to shroud a call to action.
I think a lot of PSAs come
off as slightly ineffective
because you can
tell, oh, I'm just
watching this because they want
me to click this or do that.
When you can actually
provide entertainment,
when you can actually
provide laughs
because what you're
showing is funny,
is a good piece of content
that you would go out
of your way to watch
regardless of if there
was a message attached or not--
is when we've really
seen strong success.
It's the correlation
between somebody
really enjoying
something they watch
and then going and
taking the action
that you're asking them to do.
It's so much higher
than just, like I
said, shrouding
what you actually
want them to do in
something that kind of feels
like just a cover up.
So for us, it's always been
about working with the highest
quality talent, the highest
quality writers and directors
to make sure that what we're
putting out to the world
is truly entertaining
and then is also
tied into these messages.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON:
You've kind of
touched on actually my next
question, which just fell.
I'm asking for all
of you, though.
I'd like to know what you've
learned about messaging
and what resonates with people.
How do you bring people
to your site, how
do you get people to
look at VoteRiders,
for example, or Glam Up or
"Funny or Die," generally?
What resonates?
KATE LILLY: Giveaways.
[LAUGHS]
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: T-shirts.
KATE LILLY: Well,
yeah, yeah, swag--
no, I think a lot of what I just
said really comments on that.
People are much
more incentivized
when you build trust up
over a period of time,
which is why I think "Funny or
Die" has had a lot of success.
It's because people look
at us to see something
that will make them laugh.
And if it has a
message as part of it
that allows them to laugh and
share it with their friends who
will also laugh and get that
message, that's really--
for us, video has been
a really impactful way
to see people's reactions.
And then, I think,
when we're live,
when we're doing live events,
the more appealing you can make
something, whether it's cool
talent or something unexpected
that people aren't--
When you can say, hey, we're
going to be in Detroit,
and a Pistons player will be
making a surprise appearance
doing something
you'll never imagine,
you can't even believe.
Those are things
that people say,
I'm willing to go the extra
mile for something I might not
have done, which is
register to vote,
just because I kind
of want to see that.
And that's just how we
get our foot in the door
to do everything else.
So I think it's just,
as much as you can,
putting out positive
incentives, whether it's
a funny piece of content that
you want to share or something
that you can physically
take away and experience.
I gave out ring pops once.
It really went over big.
MIKE FARAH: Ring pops
are still moving--
KATE LILLY: Yes.
MIKE FARAH: --the market, huh?
KATE LILLY: Yep.
MIKE FARAH: She touched on
something I was going to say.
I think the experience
is so important.
Everyone's so busy.
Everyone has a million shows
that they're supposed to watch.
It's kind of just overwhelming.
And so if you can
kind of crack it
by having something
really funny,
kind of in the
zeitgeist, something that
can rise to the top
and cut through.
And then, whether it's just
that viewing experience or it's
a live experience, you're
hoping that a young person,
or any person for that
matter, is taking something
that makes it stick and
makes it a memorable thing
and makes that call to action,
whether there is one or not,
organic to them.
Because they just felt
inspired by the experience.
And so it's hard to do.
And we don't get it
right all the time.
But I think the combination
of our track record
and the talent we work with
and our voice and our ability
to either add to
the conversation
or help proactively
start the conversation
are some of the things
that we lean into.
But it's not easy.
We have a good track record.
And what's actually interesting
is, even as we were building
out this national
campaign, it was
really hard to get
traditional political people
to get behind it.
It was not part of
our business plan,
but we ended up really
financing the vast majority
of the entire Glam Up
the Midterms campaign,
because we just
believed in it so much.
But you know, it's a
different industry.
And I think content
and creative,
I think people in
the traditional space
really minimize it more than
they should because they're
just from a different era.
And so we're proud of
what we've built out.
But we were actually hoping
to do even more and scale to--
I mean, at one time we
were talking about 30
plus districts.
Now we'll end up in
probably seven or eight.
So it's a very good effort.
But it's definitely
an interesting path
to have these conversations
and make these pitches
and have really the
case studies behind it
to show that these things work
in all the different ways we're
talking about.
And even though we
weren't in Hollywood,
they just gave us
the Hollywood yes.
Which is, like, oh, it's great.
Let's keep talking.
And then they wouldn't
get back to our emails.
KATE LILLY: I'll
add one thing just
to respond directly
to your question.
Which is that one big
difference we noticed--
and this was 2016
turning over into 2017--
whenever we released
a piece of content
that had some type of call
to action or messaging in it,
being present to
answer questions--
so for "Funny or Die,"
that's as simple as if you
go on our Facebook, you'll
see "Funny or Die" constantly
responds to comments--
being engaged and available
and not just shouting
something and not
being a presence to answer a
question or follow up on it
has made a huge
difference for us
in pushing people
towards doing something.
Because for a long time, our
practice was you kind of just
put it out and you
make the next thing.
You put it out and
And ever since we started that
level of engagement-- and kind
of like with your chat bot,
which I think is brilliant--
is you are there not just
to yell things at people,
you are there to engage and
help with any specific thing
that you might be
wondering about.
KATHLEEN UNGER:
So VoteRiders is--
[MICROPHONE TURNS ON]
--sorry, hello.
So VoteRiders is really
all about the facts, ma'am.
All right?
We are voter ID central.
We focus like a
laser on ID to vote.
So the messages
that we put out are
kind of a combination
of seven days a week.
It's all the articles,
what's happening,
what is happening in that world
in every state and nationally.
So people have
come to rely on it.
They know that we
are the authority.
Kate mentioned the word trust.
VoteRiders was founded
almost 6 and 1/2 years ago.
So people have come to trust
what they learn from us.
They know that they're
always going to get it
from a nonpartisan perspective.
As a matter of fact, frankly,
I'll go out of my way.
When there's a good
article, I sometimes
change the title of the article
to make it less inflammatory,
if possible.
You know, if the word
suppression's in it,
I'll do whatever I
can to not use that.
Because--
MIKE FARAH: I like to
use covert tactics.
KATHLEEN UNGER: Yeah.
It's a dog whistle for people.
MIKE FARAH: Fake news
is very effective.
KATHLEEN UNGER: Yes.
[LAUGHS] But the
substance is real.
So there's that.
And we also, of
course, are responsive,
where we're basically
on Twitter and Facebook.
And so that's the
most part that we are
and the voter stories
and all of that.
The last thing I'll
say is that when
I started this, if you
mentioned voter ID,
eyes would glaze over.
People just didn't know
what that was and frankly,
didn't particularly care.
Now they do.
And it's now right sort of in
the center of the bull's eye.
And so VoteRiders is
really on a rocket ship.
So it's really fantastic.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: All right.
I'd like to get some questions.
We have our giant blue box.
KATE LILLY: [INAUDIBLE].
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: It
does need a better name.
AUDIENCE: You didn't kill
someone today, good job.
KATE LILLY: Is
that a microphone?
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: Yes.
KATE LILLY: Of course,
it's a microphone.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So one of you
mentioned whether you're
a Republican or a Democrat.
So I'm interested to know
if you're not one of those.
Because I am not.
I've never belonged to a party.
And I have a lot
of friends that--
I actually did vote,
though, because I care.
But I have a lot
of friends that are
either independent, third
party, and they're just
really apathetic.
And so I'm wondering,
what do you recommend,
or what are you doing
to encourage that group.
Because I don't really know
how to encourage my friends.
MIKE FARAH: You haven't
tried shaming them yet?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes, every day.
KATE LILLY: [INAUDIBLE]
has good tactics.
That's a great question.
MIKE FARAH: Yeah.
Next question.
KATHLEEN UNGER: If
I could just say--
when these folks show
their newest video,
you're going to see
what they're doing
to encourage the nonvoters, OK?
I think it's
incredibly effective.
MIKE FARAH: It's a
really good question.
And we've tried lots
of different things.
In lots of ways, this hasn't
been good for our business.
It would have been easier just
to not be political at all.
KATE LILLY: Also be apathetic.
Yeah.
MIKE FARAH: Just to ignore
it-- everything in life
is easier if you're apathetic.
But that doesn't
mean life is better.
So it's a choice that we made.
And I think, broadly speaking,
we just try and connect
with people on their level.
And for friends, knowing
what your friends--
and we try and do it in a broad
way just by comedy that we
think is quality and that won't
turn that many people off--
but I think then,
it just becomes--
that's what we're trying
a lot of different things.
We're trying content.
We're trying live events.
We're trying the local activism.
We're trying celebrities.
Because you never know what
that guy or girl may respond to.
So we're trying to kind
of present a little bit
of a portfolio approach
to see what may stick.
Knowing, also, it
may not stick--
but if we can get that number
up, even just in a modest way
from 12% to higher than 12%--
to me, whether you're a
Democrat or Republican, to me,
it's just really about
the democratic process.
KATE LILLY: It's
about the process.
MIKE FARAH: And I think it only
works if people are engaged.
And you can see from the current
state of affairs what happens
when people aren't engaged.
Or rather, people
were engaged, and this
is what it got us because some
other folks weren't as engaged.
So it's tricky.
But if you believe in
it, eventually you just
have to say, give
people some options.
See what they respond to.
And then lean into the thing
so that you can manipulate them
most effectively.
KATE LILLY: I was
going to say that I
think that's why the campaign
is as nonpartisan as possible.
It's not about go
vote for this person
or go vote for that person.
It's just go be
part of the process,
regardless of who you
vote for, regardless of
if they're one of the two main
parties that are on the ballot.
Because not participating
in the process,
being apathetic to
the process, those
are the fastest ways-- for one,
for it to go away entirely,
or for two, for the value
of it to keep decreasing
and to never have the chance
to improve the process, which
is flawed in so many ways.
So I think that's, for us
at least, we do our best--
and if you watch any
"Funny or Die" content,
you'll see that we
try as hard as we
can to be to be nonpartisan.
But we do lean in a
certain direction.
But with this campaign,
specifically, it's
all about pushing out the
message of whatever you
do, go make a point that, by you
filling in a bubble, that you
are important to the country and
that this process will continue
to be something that is
unique to us as Americans.
Because we are afraid
of that not being
our future in five to 10 years.
KATHLEEN UNGER:
And if I could just
pipe in here, what also we
do is so many people have
been asking us what can we do.
People not only want
to vote, but they want
to be involved in the process.
So on our website under
the toolbar Get Involved,
you can fill out a
volunteer questionnaire.
A couple of key things, areas
in which we're especially
seeking folks, is for those who
will be virtual phone bankers
or text bankers, who we
will have a short training,
and then you'll be able to
follow up with these leads
that we're getting from our
partner organizations of people
who have voter ID questions
or who need assistance.
So there's that, which
is really important.
And then there's actually
reaching out to your networks,
all right?
It's to your networks, and
then asking your networks
to reach out to their
networks, et cetera,
to make sure that people
have the right ID to vote.
You can easily, at
VoteRiders.org in the toolbar--
the second block is something
like Get Your Voter ID.
You click on that,
and you'll see
that there's a page
for every state
and DC with our
voter cards on it,
along with some
additional information.
Because it could be your
grandmother or your brother
or your niece or somebody in
your network whom you know
you're not thinking of.
Well, yeah, does
my grandmother--
she's no longer driving--
is she in a state where
she needs an ID to vote?
Hello-- good to check that out.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON:
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
That's too far.
There's no way
I'm gonna do that.
I'll try.
KATE LILLY: Hey.
KATHLEEN UNGER: Oh!
KATE LILLY: Got some
athletes in the house.
AUDIENCE: I heard you mention
that you were focusing
on seven or eight districts.
Which ones are they, and
how did you choose them?
KATE LILLY: Well, we
worked with our team.
We have an office that works out
of DC called Funny or Die DC.
And we worked with that
team to identify areas
around the US that are
known for having low voter
turnout in specific
districts and kind of made
a priority list.
And then, from
there, it was just
about seeing watch
which organizations
we could partner with
locally to produce
an event or a video that could
geotarget that specific area.
So for us, we were in
San Diego, or Oceanside,
which was the video "California
49" that was back in May?
MIKE FARAH: April.
KATE LILLY: April-- we did a
local event in Los Angeles.
We brought everything to
DragCon, RuPaul's DragCon,
to just help the wider LA area.
We will be in Detroit,
Michigan, which
is Michigan 11 on October 7th.
And then we're hitting Phoenix,
Vegas, Milwaukee, and Houston.
And our hope is to get one or
two more cities on the docket
in October, November.
KATHLEEN UNGER: And if I
could just mention again--
so we have VoteRiders voter
ID coalition coordinators,
including in Milwaukee and in
Phoenix and a terrific partner
also in Houston.
So if we can do something
to assist your efforts.
A lot of this is
about partnerships.
That's really key to how
VoteRiders functions.
OK?
I'm in Los Angeles.
Again, California doesn't
have a state voter ID law.
But what we do is we bring
our expertise to what
everybody else is doing--
so happy to do that.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON:
Next question?
KATHLEEN UNGER: Wow.
MIKE FARAH: You guys
are used to this.
KATE LILLY: Yeah.
Did you guys practice?
AUDIENCE: So this question
is more for "Funny or Die."
So you are you planning to
reach out to the ethnic minority
communities?
KATE LILLY: You know, we're
not specifically targeting
any given majority or
minority community.
It's all really
location based, at least
for what we've done so far.
I think in general
we try everything
we can to make sure that the
events or the videos we're
putting together have
cool, diverse people who
are representing
different perspectives
and not just coming
from an LA, you
know, somebody who's from LA or
New York, the coasts, somebody
who was necessarily
even born in America.
So whether that's a performer on
stage or performer in a video,
that's really been
an effort for us.
But I think, in general,
our target is a little bit
broader, which we're saying here
are the districts and cities
that we can focus in on.
And some of those cities do have
minority populations in them,
which is definitely
part of the focus.
But we're not doing anything
specifically, I would say.
MIKE FARAH: Yeah.
I think company wide, diverse
content and inclusion--
both in front of the camera
and behind the camera--
is a huge priority for us.
I think we've always
been a little bit
ahead of the curve there.
But there's always
room for improvement.
And I think also that the event
that Kate produced at DragCon--
are you guys familiar
with DragCon and RuPaul?
That was an amazing event.
KATE LILLY: It was the
best day of my life.
[LAUGHTER]
MIKE FARAH: This isn't
the best day of your life?
KATE LILLY: This is number two.
MIKE FARAH: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
She did an amazing job,
and Billy did a great job.
And that was direct
outreach, obviously.
You know, there's lots
of different communities
at DragCon, but it obviously
overly indexes, probably,
with the LGBTQ community.
And I'm certainly not aware of
another content presentation
and creative
presentation focused
on that community in
the way that we did it
earlier this year at DragCon.
KATE LILLY: DragCon
was actually--
we were shocked to find that--
we basically put a
booth up and worked.
We handed out these cards,
which we brought some
if anybody wants one.
But it's just a "I will vote,
damn it!" commit to vote card,
with some information
on the bottom on where
you can go to register to vote.
And we handed them out.
And I'd say 75% of the people
I talked to were, like, oh, no.
I'm registered.
Don't worry.
I'm voting.
And so it was interesting to
see such a community of people
who were really--
who, yes, were probably
a minority in some sense,
at least from the
LGBTQ community, who
all were very politically aware
and very active and very ready
to say, I love that
you guys are here.
But I'm already voting.
Duh.
So it was cool to be
in the middle of that.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: It's
confidence inducing, no?
KATE LILLY: Yeah.
It is.
You're, like, oh,
great, perfect!
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for doing our job.
MIKE FARAH: It's not
all doom and gloom.
Obviously, there's a lot of
young people that do care.
And sometimes you got
to focus on those people
and just as we've been
saying encourage those folks
and make it a cool thing.
And keep the faith.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: Question?
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Kathleen.
Where did the name
VoteRiders come from?
KATHLEEN UNGER: I don't
know if you're all
aware of a group called
the Freedom Riders,
going back to the '60s and '70s.
And so it came from there.
But within the name VoteRiders
is actually voter ID -ers.
So it's--
KATE LILLY: That is brilliant.
KATHLEEN UNGER:
--it has that nice--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATE LILLY: Yeah.
KATHLEEN UNGER: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KATHLEEN UNGER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm also kind of
curious as to whether or not,
now that you have this
nice collaboration--
I'm assuming you weren't in
contact before this event--
but maybe "Funny or Die"
could do something funny
that would pull in
the voter ID stuff
as a collaborative effort?
KATHLEEN UNGER: Gotta make
it fun, so love that--
MIKE FARAH: We should
have Google pay for it.
KATE LILLY: Can
anyone greenlight
that in this audience?
MIKE FARAH: I think so.
Let's get Sergei on the horn.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Here, Matt.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Right here,
and then back there.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: This is
also for Kathleen.
So you mentioned
you are partnering
with a bunch of organizations
across the country.
Have you been partnering with
the major political parties
and the individual
campaigns to make sure
that their canvassers are
kind of getting the word out?
Or has it been mostly
grassroots, kind
of nonpartisan organizations?
KATHLEEN UNGER: So
thank you for asking.
So we do not partner
with partisan--
with candidates and
parties and all that.
The way we handle that
is, if we're in a position
where we have the opportunity
to convey voter ID information
to someone like that, we do so.
And then proactively,
Google search
for their counterpart and
proactively reach out and tell
them about our existence
and what we have to offer
and that we'd be
very happy to help
any voters who might wish voter
ID information and assistance.
And just send them our way.
So that's how we retain
our complete clean nose
nonpartisanship.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: OK.
One more question.
AUDIENCE: Is it harder for
you to cut through the noise?
MIKE FARAH: Yeah, it is.
I mean, there is a high
volume of pretty good comedy
going on around the
current state of affairs.
And also, just the speed and
volume in which things happen
makes it really hard.
KATE LILLY: Using Twitter as a
platform has changed everything
in terms of a comedy response.
MIKE FARAH: Yeah.
So for a company
like "Funny or Die,"
we just have to kind
of pick our shots.
We'll never have the resources
of an "SNL" or a "Stephen
Colbert Show" or
something like that.
So it's a combination of social
and digital and live events.
A lot of our television shows--
we produce a show called "I
Love You, America" with
Sarah Silverman for Hulu,
which is a great--
thanks-- that's a great show
that is all about inclusion
and creating the conversation
between a very divisive country
right now.
So I think because we can't
keep up with everything,
we kind of pick our shots.
And that's some of the
stuff that Kate really
did a great job of managing
and evolving when we
had a committed digital team.
It's figuring out
what are the things
that we can do that can kind
of stand out, whether it's
from a casting standpoint,
or a timeliness,
or just for a
social perspective.
We wanted our voice out there.
But hopefully with a
sensibility that didn't just
pile on, but hopefully, set the
tone in a few different ways.
KATE LILLY: We also
changed our tactic
from previous
administrations, where
the news cycle wasn't so fast.
A big story would
drop on a Tuesday.
And from our perspective,
you would have time
to write, cast, shoot,
release by Thursday.
You could get it
done in 48 hours.
But with this
administration, now there's
a big story at 10:00.
There's a big story at 2:00.
There's a big story at 5:00.
And so you have
to change tactics
in how you respond to it.
One of those big pivots
was not worrying so much
about the topical
comedy response
that a lot of the shows
that Mike mentioned
were already set up
to be able to do.
Like, they could have
a nightly response,
or with "SNL" or John Oliver,
could have a weekly response
to it and just
aggregate everything
that we had heard that week.
We decided to do take
our focus towards things
that were kind of more
broad stroke, evergreen
issues, or crazy things
about the campaign
that we could comment
on and make a really
funny piece of content around.
So that was a huge
transition for us.
And something that did
take, I mean, three months.
I'd say from
December to March, we
were, like, how do we do this?
How do we do it fast enough?
How do we keep up?
How do we get our
voice out there?
And the pivot for
us became really
smart, unexpected things that
commented on broader issues
as one.
And then the other was just
making funny things that
weren't political because
people needed a break
and giving them something
else to just come
and watch and laugh at.
NADINE FARID JOHNSON: All right.
Thank you all so much.
This has been fantastic.
Can we get a round
of applause please?
[APPLAUSE]